ALLEN ARCHULETA- ATKINS BACKER
FOR JUST BRADFORD BY ADAM
CORTESE DALLY DODD TORONTO
EGGMAN GROVE HERTZBERG HUESO
JONES LAYERED LEYVA MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ. MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
TOTAL OF BOTH. PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO STERN AMBERG AIKAU
SKI WIENER WILK. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR DORADO AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG BY SENATOR NELSON
SENATOR DORADO. GOOD MORNING
MANAGER. LOVING GOD YOU FEEL
ALL THINGS WITH THE FULLNESS
AND HOPE THAT WE CAN NEVER
COMPREHEND. THANK YOU FOR
LEADING US INTO A TIME WHERE
MORE OF REALITY IS BEING
UNVEILED FOR ALL OF US TO SEE.
WE PRAY THAT YOU WILL TAKE AWAY
OUR NATURAL TEMPTATION FOR
CYNICISM DENIAL FEAR AND
DESPAIR. HELP US HAVE THE
COURAGE TO AWAKEN TO GREATER
TRUTH GREATER HUMILITY AND
GREATER CARE FOR ONE ANOTHER.
MAYBE PLACE OUR HOPE IN WHAT
MATTERS AND WHAT LAST. TESTING
IN YOUR ETERNAL PRESENCE AND
LOVE. LISTEN TO OUR HEART'S
LONGINGS FOR THE HEALING OF OUR
SUFFERING WORLD. KNOWING
GRACIOUS GOD THAT YOU ARE
HEARING US BETTER THAN WE ARE
SPEAKING WE OFFER THESE PRAYERS
IN ALL THE HOLY NAMES
ATTRIBUTED TO YOU. A MAN.
COLLEAGUES JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE TO OUR WONDERFUL FLAG I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. SURE SAN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE HAVE SOME
SENATORS WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY THOSE ARE
SENATORS BATES GLAZER GONZALEZ
HER TADO THE MON AND SKINNER
GOOD MORNING SENATORS WELCOME.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AT THE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF
JANUARY ELEVENTH IN THE WEEK OF
JANUARY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WILL BE APPROVED AND
CORRECTED. BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
AMENDMENT MOTION MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION BERMAN WHAT
THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS THAT
CROSS THE DESK ON FRIDAY
SATURDAY AND SUNDAY JANUARY
TWENTY SECOND TWENTY THIRD AND
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THESE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
ADOPTED PUBLISHED IN THE MAJORS
RETURNED. TO COMMITTEE.
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL. TWO THIRTY SIX TO
THIRTY SEVEN TO THIRTY EIGHT
AND SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM ONE WHICH IS S.
B. EIGHTY FIVE. SENATORS
SKINNER WHO'S PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL EIGHTY FIVE BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU I'M MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING SP EIGHTY FIVE AND
THE FOLLOWING TEN MEASURES.
WHICH ARE- MEASURES. EIGHTY
FIVE TO EIGHTY NINE AND NINETY
ONE THREE NINETY FIVE SO THAT
WE MAY SEND THEM OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
BECOMING BUDGET VEHICLES THE
ASSEMBLY HAS SENT SIMILAR
NUMBER OF BILLS OVER TO OUR
HOUSE THIS IS PROCEDURAL THE
BILL SUPPRESSANT ARE ONLY
VEHICLES BUT WILL ULTIMATELY BE
AMENDED TO SERVE AS EITHER A
BUDGET BILL FOR A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. LANGUAGE WILL BE
ADDED TO THESE BILLS AS OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
SUBCOMMITTEES ENGAGE IN THEIR
HEARING PROCESS ALLOWING BOTH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THOSE
HEARING PROCESS FEES WILL ALLOW
BOTH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
PUBLIC VET THAT LANGUAGE BEFORE
RETURNS TO OUR FLOOR SO WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU SANDERS CAME SKINNER
TO. AND OR DEBATE SENATOR
NIELSEN. THAT IMPRESS LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE FOR
THE FIRST OF THESE BILLS I
BELIEVE THAT WAS EIGHTY FIVE
I'M GOING TO ASK FOR A ROLL
CALL VOTE AND A NO VOTE- I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FLOW
THROUGH. TRAILER BILL SAID I
THINK OF. THEY'RE NOT IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE
INSTITUTION BUT THE REST OF
THEM ARE WILL NOT OBJECT WILL
DO TAKE IT TAKE A ROLL CALL IN
THE SECOND IF WE MAY AND WE'LL
ALL GO ALONG WITH THAT. THANK
YOU CENTER NIELSEN MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS. AYE BAKER. I FOR
JUST. BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
AYE PROTESTING AYE DALY. DODD I
TORONTO I EGGMAN. I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. JONES
LAYERED. LAYERED. FIVE LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MEN
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. NO A SHOW
OF BOTH. PAN R. AYE PORTANTINO
I ROTH I RUBIO. I STERN AMBERG
HI WHAT KASKY. I WIENER. I WILK
NO. I TWENTY TWO NOSE TO THE
MEASURE PASSES- THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ A
THIRD TIME SENATE BILL EIGHTY
SIX THROUGH NINETY FIVE FILE
ITEMS TWO THROUGH TEN IF THERE
IS NO OBJECTION THE PREVIOUS
ROLL CALL OF TWENTY TWO EYES
AND TWO KNOWS WILL BE APPLIED
TO THE SENATE BILLS EIGHTY SIX
TO NINETY FIVE. CENTER NIELSEN.
I'M NOT A PRESIDENT IF WE COULD
I'D LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL ON
THE SECOND OF THOSE BILLS. AND
SOME OF US WILL VOTE ON THAT.
OKAY REST OF AND THEN WE CAN
JUST DO THE UNANIMOUS OR THE
NOT THE UNANIMOUS BUT I SET THE
ROLL CALL VOTE THAT WE JUST WE
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL WAIVE PRESENTATION ON FILE
ITEM TO AND WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL. SEEING NO OBJECTION MEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
AYE BECKER. I PORGES I BRADFORD
I HAVE ITEM HI FOR TESTING AYE
DALY. DODD I TORONTO I EGGMAN I
GROWTH. FROM HERTZBERG AYE
HUESO. JONES LAYERED I LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. IN
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I A TO A
BOGUS. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH. I RUBIO. I STERN. AMBERG
I WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WIENER. I
WILK NO. IS TWENTY FIVE KNOWS
ONE THE MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
NIELSEN I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT I'M CLEAR WHAT YOU'RE A
CENTER NIELSEN. I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT I AM CLEAR YOU
WOULD LIKE THE FIRST ROLL CALL
OF TWENTY TWO EYES. NOSE TO BE
APPLIED TO THE REMAINDER OF THE
BUDGET BILLS WHICH WOULD BE.
THREE THREE TEN EIGHTY SEVEN TO
NINETY FIVE YES. EXCELLENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO MEMBERS
THE FOLLOWING BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ A THIRD TIME SENATE
BILLS EIGHTY SEVEN THROUGH
NINETY FIVE ITEMS THREE THROUGH
TEN. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL OF EYES
TWENTY TWO KNOWS TO WILL BE
APPLIED TO THE SENATE BILLS
EIGHTY SEVEN THROUGH NINETY
FIVE. SEEING NO OBJECTION THE
BILLS ARE PASSED THANK YOU
MEMBERS. COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS CENTER PORTANTINO.
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WILL MEET UPON A GERMAN IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR LAYERED. IN THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ONE WILL
MEET IN FORTY TWO OH THREE UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BET A BUSINESS CENTER ACTIONS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH-
COLLEAGUES HAVE A HAVE A GOOD
AND SAFE WEEKEND FLOOR SESSION
THE NEXT ONE IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT TWO PM
THANK YOU. THINK ABOUT APPROACH
HIM THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM.
HAVE A GREAT DAY MEMBERS.